how did this how did this deal come
about and who who are you doing business
with
was it the same guy that you met in
mallorca no we don't
we don't split now he's done he doesn't
rip me off real bad okay i got to prison
i escaped from the ice they arrested me
in spain i i escaped three times
and the third time they put me in jail
there in mallorca
and so you were in jail and so in prison
in my organ city uh
i was they took me to court for
extradition i had double extradition
german is asking for my extradition for
this ashish
i hired a guy to haul the load and the
united states is asking because i owe
them 25 years special parole
and they're asking for that and they say
that they got me from moving
several million dollars with the gold
coins that they said they could have
before money laundering they said he
moved these gold coins that the united
states government would have seized
had they named it known they belonged to
reeves that was the indictment
wow carried five years and i got five
years for it but uh
germany wanted me because they just made
up some [ __ ] oh just it's anything
to get you to extradite me
so because now barry was gone they
really had nothing else on you so they
just made something up
so uh i paid the german captain of my
ship
four hundred thousand dollars to haul a
load of hashish
he uh bought and he bought him a long
cigar and a long bmw and
the police arrested him they found the
money and they said if you'll tell us
who it is you'll be home by christmas
but they didn't tell him which christmas
he got seven years
up in germany so now they've arrested me
in spain after i got away from
so much they handcuffed me this way like
over my hands this way
everywhere i go and it's very painful if
you left that way overnight
oh yeah i can imagine you can't get out
of them that way
so uh let me see so anyway they take me
to court
and mari's there and my son and i there
for the extradition hearing
and i have four guards guarding me all
my paperwork says use maximum restraints
so
because you had already escaped so and
they got my
history from uh interpol so
i'm sitting there and i talked to the
lawyer i said i wonder i'm above the
palm trees how high is this place i'm on
the third floor
he said you'll kill yourself and i said
i'm dead anyway i've got
this thing three and a half tons of
hashish charge in germany and
uh 25 years parole in america plus the
coins
right so i bound across it when two of
them leave to go smoke i bound across
the room and jumped up on the desk of
the sonographer
which is nine months pregnant and i
kicked the window out of the courtroom
and i jump up on the ledge i'm
handcuffed like
not like this no i'm in front of them oh
you're in front of any court
and uh so i looked down and it's an
awful awful long way i thought there
might be some power lines or telephone
wires i could grab on the way down and
break it but there wasn't
and there was a car parked a little bit
up on it it looked like it was a station
wagon
and i'd worked on the los angeles fire
department practice jumping in the net
from four floors so i'd bailed out and
hit the top of that car
wham and uh the room what was your
strategy when you were falling
from the i hit right on my heels and my
butt right in
and the roof cave didn't save my life
and but it went down and destroyed that
car
and there were in the uh like in a
sitting position you landed yeah
okay but more on my feet
and i still have a dead spot in my back
from that jump
it gets hot if i get upside or something
i have to get it off
so uh i uh i mean it was like
donald duck i jumped out of the car and
ran and you know the next day the
newspaper said spider-man escapes
anyhow they caught me and they asked
that i'd come to germany
and germany gave me eight years for
using a german citizen
in an international crime they didn't
have any hashish or nothing
but because i'd hired a german citizen
and he told
if he'd kept his mouth shut there'd been
nothing so i got eight years up there
so you let so you spent the next eight
years of your life in germany no after
one year i escaped from lubeck maximum
security prison what
yeah i don't think anybody ever escaped
so i went out to the bars and got all
cut up real bad and hurt and
lost my clothes and got my shoes and
this wasn't this wasn't some sort of
like tunneling escape right oh no i cut
through the went through the bars
and went and went up got on the roof and
went above the guard towers
and then i jumped down on one guard
tower by the sally port
and bailed over the fence into a pile of
dirt
a sand pile and got away and a woman
was there i watched her and it was
raining real hard and i'd lost my
clothes most of them
and i had my blue jeans on and
i watched her and a little boy come and
she brought her husband to the door and
when she went back i jumped on top of
the
the guard tower which was one floor
below me and the guy went hey
it was a tin roof and they're trained to
kill you i mean they got all these
moves out there and then i went across
and i went straight towards her so
so he couldn't shoot me and then i went
around behind the cars and was running
downhill i mean striding
and here her bam bam bam she's up on the
sidewalk
knocking the parking meters over trying
to kill me
and i jumped behind some car and she
just yeah yeah yeah yeah
at me and the little boy standing in the
seat she she tore the fender off of her
car
uh on another car trying to get me
really
i jumped over a fence and they cut my
hands all up they had glass on top of it
and i had shoes on with two hundred
dollars that mario had slipped me in the
prison
and my shoes went down i went almost
half my knees in the mud
and the blood and cut my chest all up oh
man
and uh so i took off running and lost my
shoes and my 200
now i'm barefooted and just have a pair
of blue jeans no top on
and i get away and get to holland
and you got the holland you crossed the
border across the border i had a heck of
a time at what point did you meet up
with mari
i didn't she was mad with me told me to
go back
[Laughter]
ouch why was she mad because you escaped
you destroyed my life what do you mean
oh my god that police gonna be here
anytime i can't get the papers out of
the house what did i do with them
right bury them under a rock i don't
care
so i think she was about she was tired
of it at that time
how old were you at this point when you
escaped that prison in germany uh it was
1990 so i was
uh 47 years old 47 years old
wow and what did you do when you got to
holland
i uh i met up with mari's cousin and she
had buried a hundred thousand dollars
for me on the on the place there in case
i did get out
and she told me you go to the linden
linden tree you go to the haystack and
you go to the linden tree and you turn
right and you go 10 steps
but she didn't tell me there's 20 linden
trees
we have we had fun so they were messing
with you huh no
no i mean mari just just remembered how
she got to where she buried it
so i got some iron rod and just i
finally found it
okay i got some money and then i got me
some clothes i stayed there for a while
and got a passport
and i went back to south america and
then i went back to see the colombians
and the people that i knew
and stayed there for a while and
then i got a job to take a boat to
australia with a
ton of cocaine on it
you